[Music]
we live in a very interesting time where
we have I think a combination of the
what's called expressive individualism
which is about the importance of me my
experience what makes me happy the what
we now have is something additional and
that is identity and tribal
identification where we have and I want
to say there's good part of this for one
thing that we have historically
marginalized groups women and certainly
in the workforce and the public sphere
gay people african-americans other mine
artists we've had a lot of folks who
have been in the margins of power in our
society who have said uh-uh this isn't
this isn't working anymore
so these movements towards individual
and group liberation have Anette been
very positive for our country but we
always tend to turn things towards a
kind of individualistic focus and now we
have a culture in which there is
competition for victimhood and white men
now many white men are calling
themselves victims victims of
affirmative action victims of the
liberal left okay and you have religious
groups who have tens of millions of
people in this country who are victims
of outsiders who want to destroy them
okay so so if what's happened then is I
think this expressive individualism has
been combined with the sort of the
benefits of being in an oppressed group
you know the moral high-ground that
comes with that and the and the strong
identification that comes with being
victimized group
and now everybody is in a victimized
group after the Great Recession in the
late in 2007-2008 bankers were the new
victimized group and so if there's an
there's an unhealthy trend towards
tribal competition for victim status in
our country and I want to go back and
again say there is something to a victim
but there's something too so this is
hard to talk about without saying okay
everybody should just get along and stop
complaining I'm not saying that at all
but there is something unhealthy and
what it keeps us from doing this is this
is that my main problem with it it keeps
us from working across identity groups
to solving the problems that we have
together because all all of our major
problems related to to to to poverty to
education to health care to the
environment just take any of our
problems they require cross identity
group coalition's to work on together
and when we divide into identity groups
we can't work across coalition's Martin
Luther King just before he died was
working on poverty in Croatia and across
racial coalition he knew that the that
the civil rights laws needed to be
changed there had to be a black
leadership to change those those Jim
Crow laws the next step was poverty and
poverty is not just racial and he knew
that you needed to have a broad
coalition that going to be hard nowaday
some are trying it but that is much
harder to do in a an identity based
society
[Music]